documentary filmmakers cast light on
fundamental facets of the human
condition in rigorously honest ways and
this year's nominees raised the bar
perhaps as never before the quality of
these films is breathtaking
here's to the heroes who tell the truth
for a living
the nominees for Best Documentary
Feature are the act of killing Joshua
Oppenheimer and FINA Judah Surrency
cutie and the boxer
Zachary interlink and Lydia Dean Pihl
German dirty wars richard rally and
Jeremy scale the square Jehan the same
and Kareem a man 20 feet from stardom
Morgan Neville GILF reason and patron
Rogers and the Oscar goes to 20 feet
from stardom
Morgan Neville del vision and Catrin
Rogers
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you I first want to thank along
with my producer Kate our other producer
gilfer Eason
this was his idea and it was his baby
and when I first met with him I remember
he said I want to win an Oscar
I remember thinking you're crazy that
will never happen
Gill passed away just weeks before he
premiered the film at Sundance and
tonight I know he's celebrating with us
along with his wife Janet and his son
Theo I just want to thank my backup
singers my wife Jeanette my kids say
Dean Cameron I want to thank our amazing
distributors radius in The Weinstein
Company and lastly these incredible
singers like miss Darlene love Lord God
I praise you and I am so happy to be
here representing the ladies of 20 feet
from stardom
[Applause]
the sparrow and I know he watches
[Laughter]
[Applause]